hi guys it's silver again and welcome to
another episode of my let's play and
this is actually a kind of a special
episode since everything is new in this
episode I'm using I'm currently using
honesty on my new PC to record my voice
right now it is recorded on my let's
play Park on my new PC finally I'm still
getting this thing to actually work and
I'm also gonna edit it on my new PC so
everything is new
what isn't new however is my let's play
Pike this is st. this is still the same
good old Pike that I was always working
on and honestly I didn't really feel
like working on this bike as of lately I
know that I haven't really uploaded too
many episodes of this and that's mainly
because I just didn't feel like it
anymore I just didn't like building this
park anymore so I just kind of had to
recall it sometimes and it was more like
a chore than I really wanted to do it
though the face come up so was actually
a bit better than expected but the last
couple of days I've actually been
addicted to walking on this bike III
haven't really worked in this park as
much as I have in the past couple of
days in weeks
I've just been no lifing these things
just put interning on my PC and
recording just because I couldn't record
this entire week and I just wanted to
work on this bike so expect loads of
let's play videos in over the Silver
City videos in the tutorial videos in
the near future so that's gonna be cool
now what I'm working on right now is
just a small console in the middle of
the lake I always wanted to build
something over here but I always had
problems with the lag and stuff like
that I was really hard to actually build
it and I never really had a good idea of
what I wanted to build but now I just
went for it and basically what I'm just
gonna go for is a castle that it's kind
of in the style of the orange castles
near the entrance except it's gonna it's
gonna have purple roofs and it's gonna
be a little bit more Alpine ish than
those buildings so that's gonna be the
main difference when it comes to that
and really it's just going to be a
simple building with some simple foliage
around it I don't really think it's too
much special
however the something that is special
about this is I recently got stationed
gyms what is it call again I I knew it
ghosts come in five which is a
relatively new set and it's got awesome
pieces and one of those pieces is a
chimney piece
and I really like that piece I just
tried messing around with it and decided
that it could actually be used for
corner pieces and of course that's not
what it's meant for but it's a it's that
really nice kind of medieval spooky
looking corner piece that I never had
that I suddenly found in a set that just
came out so that's why I'm actually
gonna kind of over use that in the near
future but yeah this is just a simple
castle that you're kind of used to at
this point it shares many similarities
with actually pretty much everything
except for that little corner stone in
the general shape and the fact that I'm
using alpine village for purple roofs
but really it's the same kind of glue
and well structure in a sense just the
walls from Station Jim's
I don't know what's that site called
again station Jim's castle things too
and using the windows from zero cheese
things because that side is also and all
of the extra details from castle things
and also the towers from medieval by
Ralphie and it's actually a combination
that turned out to work really well like
I still have my doubts about this and I
remember when I just started working on
this park that I was like okay I'm gonna
make a park and the theme is gonna be
well medieval steampunk Alpine and it's
it's really a weird idea and I don't
know why I came up with that in the
first place but it actually works out in
a sense and the more that I'm building
and also I'm gonna add foliage in this
in this episode and it actually turns
out that foliage really helps this park
like it usually always helps park and
help spikes look better with foliage but
especially with this park since there's
so many empty grasslands everywhere and
there are hills and castles and
everything it just works well with the
foliage so that not just went
surprisingly well like if I if I still
had my doubts about this park and
whether I actually wanted to continue it
because I was actually at some point
thinking about dropping this bike
altogether then adding foliage to it
kind of eliminated all of those thoughts
because it just turned out that foliage
is just finished the job and it just
made it looks
difficult ly better so that's that's
really cool and now the general shape of
this castle it's kind of well almost
finished yeah it's not too complicated
of a building just towers and walls I
don't know if I can still say that I
know that I've been saying this for
quite a while but when you're building
medieval medieval things or you really
need to do to make a building look good
aside from of course good shape and good
detail it's just added I see a ton of
towers really that's that's not all
there is to it but it's actually trick
that sounds stupid and over-the-top but
it works and over the top is also kind
of what I'm going for them with this
bike because it's honestly you're not
going to have any real life theme parks
building enormous castles like that even
Disney probably doesn't have the money
to do that and also the free fly coaster
has a ridiculous amount of scenery in
terms of rock work and all those Alpine
houses you can't just build that as a
real park so if you are going for a
realistic rollercoaster or a realistic
park in general then I would suggest not
doing what I'm doing right now but it's
still something that I have fun with
doing especially at this point oh and
now you can see by the way that the
graphics might look a little bit
different and that's because I mean to
clusion better shaders and all that but
it only works when I have the grid on
which is actually a good thing like it
took me a while to actually realize this
because the first I was like hey where's
my ambient occlusion what are you doing
give me back my good graphics but then
it turns out that when I turn the grid
on
I mean inclusion is gone as well and
that's actually a good thing because
kind of well for one it kind of makes it
easier to concentrate but that's really
not the main thing it's just cool to
have an option to turn ambient occlusion
on off when you want it because it does
save some performance and when you're
doing foliage and stuff like that you
can always turn the grid off so you can
always see the way that it looks with
ambient occlusion on and when recording
a video of a coaster of course I'm not
going to leave the grid on so it doesn't
really matter in that case but yeah
working on the foliage and the rock work
which is very important as you might see
I'm using Weber's large rocks
hallelujah it works again like I tried
opening this Pike for loads of times I I
don't even I can't even count how many
times but it's probably nearly 30 though
I don't really mind that much because
with my new computer it doesn't take as
long as on my laptop to start up but
it's still it's still annoying but it
turns out that webOS large rocks is
working now the only cause some scenery
problem that I need to still need to fix
is something that you might have noticed
when I was scrolling through the custom
scenery but then again it's it's a time
lapse so it's hard to notice it but some
sets I don't just have some sets twice
in my list but three times so I've like
three different clones of one set in my
custom scenery list and that's not just
one set I think it's all of CTR since
part sets yeah and also some of branches
sets and I really need to figure out
which sets I've used in which sets I
have in and where all the clones are
within style themed but other than that
after a couple of days of working and
not being able to make videos I finally
got everything to work and I was able to
make videos yesterday and today and now
I'm sitting here doing my well my thingy
again so that's really cool and yeah
rook work is just the same as everything
else but foliage is where it gets more
interesting because I decided to as
over-the-top as the buildings are and
possibly also be unrealistic a bit
unrealistic it's very unrealistic
honestly I decided to just [ __ ] logic
and do foliage in a ridiculous way just
I think I've used about maybe eight or
seven nine sets like that symbol on that
and all kinds of trees and just mixing
so many things that it barely makes any
sense but it looks really cool so might
as well I don't think if I can actually
name all of the sets but I might be able
to okay let's give this issue let's give
this a shot so basically what you're
seeing now is Asian sensation by the way
I hate the name of the set of that set
like it's called Asian sensation and it
just doesn't right it just doesn't rhyme
they
my OCD doesn't like that but that's
besides the point so I've used that site
then there's also station gyms gardening
- obviously station Gymkhana inning one
and station gyms gone in to point five
so that's already four sets then there
is and sevens floors which I've used for
the flowers and think I've used out
early in earlier videos as well yeah as
well as and sevens ornamental shrubs so
that means seven and on an and sevens
ornamental trees are also important so
that means eight sets and then we've
still got alt splices trees for all the
oaks and the pines that I was placing
just a minute ago and of course those
awesome birches now really cool - that's
nine sets and oh I think that's it
though you can also count waivers
foliage but I'm not really sure because
I only used up with small shrubs so I
think it'll be nine sets well that's
still ridiculous though I I mean
normally foliage to be realistic
shouldn't be as diverse it's it's always
good to add diverse foliage but if you
want to stay to the point and realistic
then it's probably not the best idea but
I just wanted to go over the top with
this just like the buildings and if you
want foliage that looks nice but isn't
necessarily realistic then you might
always go with loads of different trees
that's really cool so I decided to do
that and as you can see it does take
some time to fill it all in because
every single tree that your place has to
be placed correctly and you have to kind
of mess around with it and that's why it
takes a little bit well more time but
it's still cool and as you can see I'm
using a checkerboard terrain pattern but
anyway that's it for this episode so
thank you for watching and bye